wenn wir so weit sind und das ist ja
offensichtlich die idee dieses vorgangs
dann
wird es ein anderer staat ein anderes
zusammenleben ist wenn man das ist der
mann und er rechtfertigt dass er sagt
bürgerinnen und bürger können damit
sicher und anonym verstöße gegen straf
und steuergesetze melden genau viele
grüße deine stasi also das ist ja im
grunde die nicht mit geschriebene
unterschrift so hat unter anderem dieses
schreckliche ddr system funktioniert wer
sich nicht an die regeln hält wird schön
verpetzt beim staat also wir sehen hier
dass die grünen kein freiheitlichen
grundbegriff sind die reden immer von
liberalität von toleranz von freiheit
und dann sagen sie einem den nachbar
spitzel den block hat auf den hals das
ist sozusagen etwas wo wir schon acht
geben müssen denn der mann ist ja nicht
irgendwer sondern einen minister in
baden württemberg und gut vernetzt bei
manchen vorschlägen der grünen kann man
ja der anschließend sagen okay das ist
jetzt die grüne jugend oder das ist mir
noch sprengt da irgendwo aus
hintertupfing der den vorschlag gemacht
hat in baden württemberg regieren die
grünen seit langem unter winfried
kretschmann und dieser mann daniel bahrs
ist ganz talentierter frischer politiker
kommt aus dem bundestag dort als
finanzminister ein ganz erfahrener mann
in finanzfragen interessanter mann
übrigens auch der ist verheiratet mit
katharina schulze der jungen grünen aus
bayern so bisschen so ein grünes
glamour-paar die beiden und wenn der
jetzt diesen vorschlag macht ist dass
die großen vorschlag sondern das kommt
halt es kommt und du hast ja gerade den
ministerpräsidenten kretschmann erwähnt
ich finde ketsch man muss diesen unsinn
stoppen ich habe kretschmann immer als
ein liberalen wahrgenommen als ein mann
der auf und seine lebenserfahrung
profitiert der bai koroma ein bisschen
aus dem bild gewandert ist mit sub
dirigistischen vorschlägen aber diesen
unsinn seines ministers muss ja
eigentlich sofort stoppen oder sich
zumindest heute zu äußern man muss aber
auch sagen gleichzeitig gibt es ja
bereits die möglichkeit der
steuerverwaltung verstöße zu melden also
müssen sich dann nur die mühe machen
dann da hinzulaufen oder eine e mail zu
schreiben oder anzurufen jetzt aber
dieser schritt dass man da einfach im
system das digital eintippen kann ist
für dich nochmal ein weiter zu sagen
also da ist die grenze aber wir haben in
como darüber dass selbst der pranger für
oder gegen sexualstraftäter nicht kommt
also wenn man wüsste dass neben einem
einen sexualstraftäter wohnt dann darf
man auch nicht sagen rudi hat wieder
kontakt zu kleinen kindern aber bei der
steuer geht es und damit ist es viel
viel viel viel breiter und es ist im
grunde auch für mich nicht nur dieser
einzelfall sondern das denken das
dahintersteht ich mache mir sorgen wenn
die grünen in eine machtposition kommen
diese grünen nicht die grünen des
joschka fischer diese grünen dann haben
wir sozusagen eine moral polizei mit
allen instanzen und das glaube ich schon
noch mal sich durch den kopf gehen zu
lassen bevor man sie welt wobei
steuerhinterziehung keine frage von
morales ganz klar es geht hier um das
mittel der wahl natürlich ist
steuerhinterziehung hart zu bestrafen hc
verfolgen und dania bayers begründet
dass wie vorher sagt steuerbetrug ist
eben kein kavaliersdelikt bis hierhin
unterschreiben wir das glaube ich alle
ich hoffe dass andere bundesländer
nachziehen werden sagt er also eher
aktiviert jetzt da eine mehrheit im
bundesrat ja die oder dann auch der bund
wenn die grünen mitregieren oder gar die
kanzlerin stellen also das ist die
aufforderung für eine kollektive für ein
kollektives system der denunziation und
hier müssen wir ein stoppschild
errichten und ganz aufmerksam hingucken
denn so will glaube ich niemand
zusammenleben
[Musik]